how old were you when you took your
first rip of weed weed I was third well
not really see I smoked when I was
younger but it was only like
occasionally at like a party and always
felt like a loser for doing it you know
like everybody else would be getting
high and I'm a hoot and but I was
probably already drunk anyway you know
like when I was 14 or 15 or something
like that so maybe I smoked weed a
handful of times less than a dozen times
until I was 30 and then Eddie Bravo got
me into it when I was 30 years old we
were doing jiu-jitsu together and he was
telling me how marijuana is helping his
jiu-jitsu and helping his music and his
creativity I was like what the [ __ ] is
this guy talking about my tube marijuana
just makes you stupid
I don't you know if you know and he's
like just try it and what and he we got
high and I remember thinking like oh
this is what it is
like wow I did not know saying I believe
that feeling like you like me by
yourself it's this no it's me Eddie oh
oh sorry I can't believe this we went
got somebody II walk in oh yeah we
didn't look like crazy they talked about
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] and then I
remember I started smoking pot and
getting on stage and I've got rules
we're getting real creative with my
comedy and then smoking pot and doing
jiu-jitsu it was like I can't believe
houses owned in it gets you with
training smoking pot and hittin the bag
to this day is like one of my all-time
favorite things I get I get I get
freaked out but I just wrap up my hands
put on the timer and just once that
sweat starts flowing and you start and
it's almost like the paranoia and the
weirdness of it all you just fight it
off by hitting that bag ba-ba-boom
ba-ba-boom you know and you you hear the
bell that says 30 seconds and you're
Florian and then you get that one minute
off to think about life and the future
and the [ __ ] universe and volcanoes
and Guatemala and Hawaii and oka the
belt goes off again you got another
three rounds three minutes and man it's
one of my my Blake it's a it's a
psychedelic experience it's like a
cleansing experience
hitting the bag when you're high I like
I love shadowboxing when I'm high I'll
take a rip out at home and just sit and
they have a little mirror and I'll just
shadow box don't even know how long I
just can just shadow Boxford let's go do
you know what's weird like you feel
balance when you're high you feel like
like maybe like if you got an injury you
feel it more you feel like we're wounds
are off you know what I mean and like
for me I feel my transfer of power
better when I'm high like the like
certain techniques I really get the
timing of like when to turn the hip over
I feel it more when I'm high like I feel
the connection with all the tissue all
of it working together